hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show officially tolerated by Dan
Harmon sure Rick and Morty season 3's
finale may have just aired but today my
sights are set on the episode that came
before the ABCs of Beth which had one of
the most ambiguous endings in the
history of the series and had the
potential to forever change everything
we thought we knew about a member of the
show's main cast now at this point you
all know that where there's ambiguity in
a show there are theories to be had and
I think that I have this one pretty well
solved you can pull the wool over
everyone else's eyes there Dan but not
this guy after last week's CLAB were
like totally soul bonded now or at least
I like to think so
you understand how serious croute
Ambulance soul bonding is the character
in question is Beth the unfulfilled
mother of the Smith family who gets a
chance to revisit through peel and her
imaginary childhood world with the
single dumbest name possible you know if
you're so great at naming things why
don't you do it from now on well there
Beth is horrified to learn that FRU peel
and is now ruled over by her childhood
friend Tommy who she may or may not have
tried to kill out of jealousy as a kid
well that's interesting
fake news in order to survive in this
fantasy world Tommy has had to resort to
an endless cycle of incest and
cannibalism it's basically the most
disturbing version of Jumanji ever I'm
an overweight middle-aged man wait a
second where's my phone
okay second most disturbing version of
Jumanji ever fast-forward to the end of
the episode Beth tries to bring Tommy
back to reality in order to reunite him
with his family and save his father's
life his father who happens to be on
death row supposedly guilty for Tommy's
disappearance
Tommy though refuses to leave his incest
Kingdom and Beth has no choice but to
gruesomely finish the job that she
started back when she was like 7 bricks
suggest that they solved the dead Tommy
problem by creating a clone of Tommy
with the finger that he's so happily
donated to Beth during her murderous
rampage thereby acquitting Tommy's
father of the child murder charges they
do so and with an innocent man freed a
family reunited and the day saved Beth
spirals into some existential angst dad
I'm out of excuses to not be Who I am so
Who am I what do I do
Rick then drops a bombshell saying that
the same process that they used to
create the clone of Tommy
could also be used to create a clone of
Beth allowing Beth to go off on whatever
soul-searching journeys that she wants
while the clone takes care of the kids
back at home after staring at some
photos of her family Beth comes to a
decision and then the show immediately
cuts away without us ever knowing what
that decision is the next time that we
see her and Rick though they're behaving
very differently very affectionate even
dropping the dreaded L word I love you
dad love you too sweetie the episode
ends and leaves us with one question are
three boobs truly better than two sorry
that's the B storyline leaves us with
one question did Beth choose to stay or
did she replace herself with a clone it
may seem like the creators of the show
have made it impossible for us to know
for sure that the show actually gives us
all the information that we need to
figure it out definitively throughout
this episode clocks and references to
exact units of time are everywhere first
we get a glimpse of the clock in the
execution chamber when Beth and Rick
prevent Tommy's father from being
lethally injected it reads 156 and this
gives us our starting point we can
assume that shortly after that Rick and
Beth start to head home we know that
they drive home and don't use the portal
gun because we see them actually walk
through the front door this also makes
sense since they were transporting Tommy
who needed to stay unaware of bricks
crazy scientific schemes so we know for
a fact that they were at the execution
chamber around 2:00 p.m. and it would
take some time for them to return from
the execution site back to their home
where Rick eventually makes his cloning
but how long would that take well we can
calculate the distance between the two
locations we know for a fact thanks to
Justin roiland Twitter account that the
Smith residence is canonically located
in the suburbs outside of Seattle
Washington this is a weird factoid that
I never really thought about but makes a
lot of sense now that I'm researching it
it's not like every city has their own
execution chamber just waiting to be
used in fact there is only one execution
chamber in the entire state of
Washington and it's located at the State
Penitentiary in Walla Walla Washington
a four and a half hour drive away from
the Seattle area that means that even if
beth's were in a rush to get home after
the 2:00 p.m. execution these soonest
that she would be arriving back at the
Smith residence would be around 6:30
p.m. mark it down because it's the
crucial point in our timeline when they
get back to the house Beth indicates
that she's exhausted and ready to call
it a day it's only after this point that
Rick gives best the talk and reveals
that he has the ability to replace her
with a clone we know from earlier in the
episode with Tommy that the process of
growing a clone takes around three hours
also worth pointing out it's an oddly
suspicious detail for the writers to
include their rights almost like they
wanted us to know this information for
some reason anyway regardless this means
that the absolute soonest that Rick
could possibly have a clone ready to
replace her wit would be around 9:30
p.m. provided everything goes perfectly
but waits
freeze frame the clip of the kids coming
home at the end of the episode look out
the window it's broad daylight does that
look like 9:30 p.m. anywhere in the
world to you even at Seattle's northern
latitude which does give it longer days
during the summer the longest day of the
year has it sunset at around nine
o'clock p.m. even then the longest day
of Seattle's year by 9:45 it would
already be dark outside which means that
the final scene we see of the Smith
family has to happen at around 8:30 p.m.
at the latest it's certainly enough time
for best to get back from the Washington
State Penitentiary but definitely not
enough time for Rick to have created a
clone to replace her in that final scene
ergo the Beth that we see in this final
scene must be the real deal she is a
hundred percent authentic Beth Smith it
turns out she decided to stay at home
and be a mother to her children rather
than head out on some whack
fantastical soul-searching adventure the
adventure she chose for herself in that
moment was motherhood okay so now let's
deal with some challenges that I'm sure
I'm gonna hear in the comments first
maybe all this is happening on a
separate day but we can prove for a fact
that it's not at the beginning of the
episode we hear that the kids are late
for their custody weekend with Jerry
aren't you guys supposed to be at your
father's for custody weekend and we hear
on the TV that the execution is
happening quote tomorrow so we know that
the episode is starting on a Saturday
and execution is happening on a Sunday
we see Saturday night midway through the
episode so we know that everything
around the clones is happening on Sunday
the day of Tommy's father's execution we
also know that the kids are headed back
home Sunday evening and not Monday
morning because the pizza place
Renaldo's is closed because it's too
late I think our na house is closed and
lastly we know that this show doesn't
cheat time dimension-hopping yes but
messing around with time is a big no-no
on Rick and Morty just take it from my
buddy Dan time travel is a real shark
jumper Plus Rick even reminds us at the
end of the episode that there are no
time-travel shenanigans to be had by the
way that wasn't time travel which means
that all evidence considered we can
definitively say that Beth is real it
was like the show's creators were
drawing our attention to these details
to ask us to solve the mystery on our
own just like I'm drawing your attention
to the subscribe button right now so
that you can solve the mystery of
subscribing on your own that way you can
be notified of more Rick and Morty
series in the future click it and while
you're down there next to the comments
let me know in three seconds whether you
think at the end of the episode was Beth
real or was she a clone just one worth
real or clone curious how many of you I
was able to convince now I know that
some fans have been picking apart that
scene trying to figure out whether the
Beth we see at the end is a clone based
on her behavior debating about whether
she's acting more affectionate than the
real Beth would but in this episode we
don't need to psychoanalyze anyone to
come up with the truth the solution was
right there waiting to come out it was
all just a matter of time but hey that's
just a theory a film theory and cut
and by the way special thanks to Reddit
user deaths coming 23 who got me to look
into this theory on the game theorist
subreddit you're a suggestion to look at
the clocks was awesome and also just as
a reminder
I don't talk about it all that much but
if you guys have a theory request or
just a theory of your own the best way
for me to see it is actually on the game
theorist or film theorist subreddit yes
some loyal theorists actually created
one for film theory too I'm trolling
around there pretty frequently to see
what you guys are excited to see covered
and if you have any great theory
starters of your own so check them out
if you haven't and hey if you missed my
collaboration with Rick and Morty
creator himself Dan Harmon picking apart
the science of pickle Rick well that
video link is on your left to the right
is something that YouTube has
algorithmically determined that you'll
want to watch next let's see how good of
a job it does see you next week for
something that's a little bit more
emotive